alireza akbari served as the deputy
defense minister during the former uh
during the tenure of the former
president Muhammad katami he was seen as
a relative reformer at the time 1997 to
2005 and he would have had access to
extremely sensitive material the
Iranians saying he was spying for MI6
for British intelligence at the time and
a news agency associated with Iranian
intelligence has said in the last hour
he was one of the most important
infiltrators of the country's sensitive
and strategic centers agbara he was
arrested in 2019 he says he was
interrogated for 10 months tortured
given mind-altering drugs and then
forced to confess to crimes he says that
he did not commit he was then sentenced
by Iran's revolutionary court and what
we believe and the judicial process in
Iran is opaque to say the least but what
we believe is that his appeal was
rejected by the Supreme Court of that
country and we know from comments made
to made by his wife to the meat media
his wife Maryam that she has been
granted a last meeting with her husband
we also believe that akbari has been
moved to solitary confinement in his
prison and that is a strong sign that
his execution is imminent in response to
this James cleverly the foreign
secretary has tweeted in the last few
minutes Iran must halt the execution of
British Iranian alirez akbari and
immediately release him this is a
politically motivated act by a barbaric
regime that has a total disregard for
human life so strong words from the
foreign secretary